you know if you were 16 again or 15
again and
ufc or mma was on the table as well as
boxing would would you
just be a die-hard boxer be a boxer i
would get paid more money
yeah regardless mma is
like ufc the biggest thing in the world
make all the money and everything
but boxers always have 10 times more
money than um
yeah ufc fighters why is that hey i have
no idea
the other one's drawing the money yeah i
don't know yeah
how did that there was some some banter
between you and jon jones about maybe
you said
you said if you want to get paid john
jones you're gonna have to fight me only
just saying in order for them because
the pay you know the paid difference
between a boxer and an mma guy
he'd have to do what um conor did fight
floyd and he
was like me to make that big money like
a hundred million something like that
right suggest the month the money is
that's where the money is
mma fighting against boxing guys you
know
first um they could do boxing and some
guys could just try mna
somebody have to try mna i know some
boxers
but what surprised me i didn't expect um
mcgregor to do that well yeah
you know i expect the floyd to wipe him
off just humiliate him embarrass him
i didn't expect him to do that well that
impressed me that he last 10 rounds with
the greatest fighter in the last 30
years
40 years you know right that was
impressive
he took his beating like a man didn't
complain that was just
that was just impressive do you uh do
you talk to floyd mayweather
not much periodically if i see him if i
have something to say to him
how about how about 50 cent i took the
50 cent
pretty often when i see him yeah
50 is a boxer yeah why do you think
having floyd shabop
what i mean dude they go back and forth
their buddies then they're not buddies
and their buddies and
right oh no they're buddies
yeah dude